madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal en corse l'audition du témoin de
matignon il s'agit de clotilde valter
chargé des affaires de sécurité qui a
remis au juge des photocopies de ces
carnets nouvelle polémique autour du
rôle de l'état dans la sphère du sang
contaminé note adressée à claude evin en
89 envisager l'hypothèse de ne pas
rappeler les transfusés à rouen la
grandiose armada une trentaine de vieux
gréements de voiliers de légende à quai
pour cette parade de maritime unique et
puis l'ouverture du festival d'avignon
avec l'événement la création d'henry 5
ils cessent de shakespeare jamais joué
en france dans le rôle titre à moins
d'une heure et demie de son entrée en
scène philippe torreton que nous
retrouverons en fin de journal pour une
page spéciale consacrée à cette 53e
édition du festival d'avignon
quelques mois après le procès du sang
contaminé un nouvel élément vient
alimenter un peu plus la polémique
autour du rôle de l'état à la fin des
années 80 il s'agit d'un document publié
ce matin par nos confrères du parisien
une note adressée au ministre de la
santé claude evin l'encourageant à ne
pas alerter les transfusés des risques
de contamination et ce pour éviter un
battage médiatique qu'olivier caroff
venez venez de 1981 à 1985 7000
personnes ont contracté le sida lors
d'une opération médicale quatre ans
pendant lesquels des milliers de poches
de sang contaminé par le virus ont été
utilisés c'est fait claude evin en a eu
connaissance
en 1989 il était alors ministre de la
santé
pourtant il n'a pas jugé utile d'alerter
explicitement tous les transfusés pour
lui cela n'aurait pas été efficaces et
risquer de provoquer la panique mais une
note reçue par claude evin le 13
décembre 89 relance aujourd'hui la
polémique
elle est signée jean françois girard à
l'époque directeur général de la santé
il alerte son ministre sur
l'indemnisation des transfusés le risque
majeur écrit-il est une médiatisation à
rebours en faveur des revendications des
transfusés et une coordination de leurs
demandes
un des effets pervers est temps que les
transfusés puisse identifier un groupe
et devenir un groupe de pression c'était
de mon devoir d'informer les ministres
des de la médiatisation et des groupes
de pression mais c'est normal et je
comprendrais très bien que les
transfusés organisé en association
cherche à obtenir le même dispositif que
celui qui allait être mise en place pour
les hémophiles
voilà et c'est pour ça que le mot de de
médiation et lobby a été utilisée c'est
pas pour les pointes de s'impliquer
public et dépistage l'association
française des transfusés qui a porté
plainte et obtenu la mise en examen de
claude evin voit dans cette note la
confirmation de ces soupçons
aujourd'hui il est prouvé que c'est bien
par crainte d'un scandale de la
constitution d'une association transfusé
de poursuites éventuelles qu'on a
préféré laisser s'accroître le nombre de
morts pour protéger les responsables des
contaminations initial claude evin lui
juge cette note maladroite mais dit
pouvoir prouver qu'il n'a pas cherché à
étouffer le scandale
en corse la conseillère de lionel jospin
pour les affaires de sécurité a été
entendu à titre de témoin aujourd'hui
une audition au cours de laquelle
claudine valter a remis rejuge des
photocopies de ces carnets qu'évoquait
bernar venet carnets dans lesquels
auraient été consigné ses conversations
avec l'ex préfet de corse michel fine
abd el djeich à matignon elle était le
contact du préfet bonnet clotilde valter
énarque 37 ans est conseiller technique
auprès du premier ministre chargé des
questions de sécurité et donc de la
corse
clotilde valter et bernard bonnet se
téléphoner deux à trois fois par jour
ils se voyaient souvent leur dernier
rendez-vous remonte au 27 avril dit
jours avant la garde à vue du préfet
c'est bernard bonnet qui avait demandé à
rencontrer clotilde valter mais aussi
alain christnacht conseiller du premier
ministre pour les affaires intérieures
la suite est racontée par bernard bonnet
dans cette lettre envoyée au juge
d'instruction
au cours de cet entretien écrit le
préfet je leur ai précisément exposer
les éléments dont je dispose est sur
l'instant ni de la paillote clotilde
valter a soigneusement noté mes propos
dans un de ces cahiers personnel madame
valter a pour habitude de consigner dans
ses cahiers le contenu des conversations
le juge d'instruction a reçu cette
lettre lundi le lendemain et convoqué
clotilde valter ce matin le conseiller
du premier ministre n'a pas apporté au
juge ses cahiers personnel dans son
cartable
juste quelques photocopies des cahiers
concernant notamment la journée du 27
avril
elle y aurait consigné la version livrée
ce jour-là par bernard bonnet le pré
s'est affirmée alors ne pas avoir été
informé du projet d' incendies de la
paillote quand il de valter est resté
dans le bureau du juge en tout plus de
quatre heures et demie avant de repartir
en fin d'après-midi vers paris sur le
fond du dossier l'audition de clotilde
valter n'aurait pas apporté d'éléments
très nouveau elle n'aurait pas permis
non plus de dédouaner comme il semblait
l'espérer l'ancien préfet de corse
devant les juges petit de valter c'est
en effet remémorer les impressions
qu'elle a gardé de sa dernière rencontre
avec le préfet bernard bonnet le 27
avril dernier
ce jour-là elle l'aurait trouvé plutôt
gêné assez confus dans ses explications
et plutôt moins à l'aise qu'à l'habitude
et jean pierre chevènement a une
nouvelle fois rappelé à bernard benêt
son devoir de réserve bernard benêt qui
aurait une nouvelle fois réaffirmé avoir
été victime d'un piège judiciaire on
connaît désormais la composition de la
commission européenne qui siègera dès
septembre prochain une équipe neuve pour
un nouveau départ après le scandale qui
avait éclaboussé la commission comme
nous vous l'indiquions hier pascal lamy
et michel barnier ont reçu
respectivement le portefeuille du
commerce extérieur et de la politique
régionale le détailler le fonctionnement
de ce gouvernement des cases arnaud
goûter
une équipe de haute volée les loges
vient du président de la commission
européenne romano prodi lors de sa
conférence de presse il concerne les dix
neuf commissaires qui vont l'entourer à
bruxelles aujourd'hui les portefeuilles
ont été distribués les deux vice
présidences reviennent à l'angleterre et
l'espagne
côté français le rpr michel barnier
décrochent les aides régionales
le deuxième poste du budget européen le
socialiste pascal lamy lui a longtemps
travaillé à bruxelles aux côtés de
jacques delors
il s'occupera du commerce extérieur un
dossier stratégique dans quelques mois
s'engage de nouvelles négociations pour
la libéralisation des échanges tous
siègeront ici dans ces fauteuils
qu'occupent quelques semaines encore
l'équipe démissionnaire de jacques
santer mais question à quoi servent les
commissaires et comment fonctionne
l'union européenne
cela repose sur une subtile division du
travail entre les quatre lieux de
pouvoir la commission le conseil
européen celui des ministres et le
parlement
chaque décision suit un parcours
complexe pour un objectif tout simple la
recherche du consensus qui décide au
sein de l'union
toutes les institutions sauf la
commission celle-ci ne fait que proposer
des directives des règlements ou des
actes communautaires
ensuite elle exécute et contrôler les
applications aujourd'hui romano prodi
promettent une transparence absolue dans
le nouveau fonctionnement
après la crise il veut rétablir l'image
de marque et surtout ne pas perdre trop
de pouvoir face au parlement de
strasbourg qui dans quelques semaines
doit auditionner tous les nouveaux
commissaires au kosovo un contingent
italien de la kfor aurait découvert ce
qui pourrait être le plus gros charniers
incite au sud de pécs qui compterait
trois cent cinquante cadavres par
ailleurs comme chaque jour maintenant de
nouvelles manifestations
antigouvernementales avec à quelques 300
km au sud de belgrade
la confrontation des pros et antis
milosevic l'opposition au leader serbe
s'amplifie gagne du terrain même si pour
l'instant la contestation ne s'est pas
organiser ouvertement à belgrade
chirac les specs
pour la première fois depuis la fin de
la guerre partisans et adversaires de
slobodan milosevic se retrouvent face à
face avant ces avancées les traîtres
détruisez tout c'est ça que vous voulez
10 aux partisans du régime vous devriez
barreaux vous êtes des ordures de
communistes réponse un opposant ça fait
cinquante ans que vous piller son peuple
malgré tout le meeting de l'opposition
se déroule comme prévu l'ancien général
démissionnaire vous qu'obradovic et
ovationné enfant du pays
il préside aujourd'hui le parti
social-démocrate opposition et scoops
les dirigeants se promène en voiture de
luxe et se pare de kilos d'or en forme
de bijoux au cabc nouvelle interruption
car les partisans du président milosevic
ont déployé une banderole insultante en
termes très crus l'opposition
zoran djindjic responsable du parti
démocrate prend alors la parole pour
rendre hommage au président du
monténégro nouvel incident mais cette
fois plus graves le préfet a tiré en
l'air et se fait traiter d'assassin les
policiers eux expliquent qu'ils ne sont
au courant de rien un meeting décidément
houleux qui montrent que chacun des deux
camps mobilise ses troupes alors que
l'opposition cherche à manifester chaque
jour dans une ville différente avant de
se conter à belgrade
en egypte la rencontre alexandre et
entre sni moubarak et le nouveau premier
ministre israélien qui entame une
tournée diplomatique au coeur de ces
deux heures d'entretien le processus de
paix au proche orient avec la volonté
affichée du chef du gouvernement
israélien ehoud barak d'avancer sur la
voie de la paix simultanément avec les
palestiniens les syriens et les libanais
autour en france au chapitre économique
martine aubry a donc finalement bouclé
son projet de la deuxième loi sur les 35
heures de nouvelles dispositions
concernant notamment le temps de travail
des cadres avec un nombre de jours de
congés supplémentaires le détail avec
sébastien guibert jacques gérard alors
ça existe aujourd'hui martine aubry a
donc tenu compte des critiques
les syndicats avaient unanimement
reproché à son avant projet de loi
sa faiblesse en matière de temps de
travail des cadres ce matin la ministre
de l'emploi dans son projet définitif
s'est voulue rassurante
les cadres ne seront pas exclues de la
loi ne demandons pas l'impossible nous
savons pour beaucoup de cadres
aujourd'hui en france travailler 35
heures ce n'est pas possible et
d'ailleurs il ne le réclame pas de cette
manière là mais ce qu'ils veulent c'est
avoir du temps pour eux solution passer
aux 35 heures comme les autres salariés
ou bénéficiez de 10 jours minimum de
congés supplémentaires dans ce cas la
durée du travail est calculé en nombre
de joue aujourd'hui en france
les cadres en moyenne travail 227 jours
par an l'avant-projet en prévoyait 222
ce sera finalement 217 un mode de calcul
critiqué par la cgt et la cgc en ne
comptant le temps de travail quand jour
on en revient au mode de calcul duc
avait cours au 19e siècle pour
l'ensemble des salariés
c'est à dire à une époque
où le travail salarié était le plus
exploité rien n'empêchera à ce moment là
les employeurs de nous faire travailler
douze ou quinze heures par jour et ça ne
se traduira manifestement pas par une
baisse de notre temps de travail
pour martine aubry les problèmes se
régleront par la négociation entreprise
par entreprise et toutes les solutions
sont envisagées l' usage de la pointeuse
entre autres pourraient se généraliser
ernest antoine seillière le président du
medef a qualifié cet après midi cet
avant-projet de plus complexe et plus
rigide que le précédent texte dominique
strauss kahn commentant les chiffres de
la dette publique a affirmé aujourd'hui
qu'il poursuivrait un effort rigoureux
de maîtrise des dépenses et ce pour
obtenir en l'an 2000 des déficits
publics sous le seuil des 2% du produit
intérieur brut dans les départements de
l'allier le projet d'implantation d'une
société américaine d'élevage de chiens
destinés à la ville vivisection mobilise
les militants depuis plusieurs mois
différentes communes de la région
avaient montré leur hostilité à
l'installation de cette entreprise
la polémique se poursuit géraldine
d'alban morenas
une dernière piqûre voici comment
finissent chaque année des milliers de
chiens de laboratoire fournit par des
éleveurs spécialisés
c'est contre que se dressent les
militantes de l'association tally depuis
plusieurs semaines ils multiplient les
actions
pétitions manifestations tous les moyens
sont bons pour empêcher une société
américaine
marshall funds d'implanter dans l'allier
un élevage de 2000 biggles des chiens
tous destinés à des laboratoires
scientifiques on pratique des tas
d'expériences dès l'âge de six semaines
ils peuvent être utilisés en tests de
toxicologie
c'est à dire des produits chimiques qui
leur sont injectées où on les force à
absorber des produits chimiques jusqu'à
ce qu'il meure pour voir quelle quantité
va les faire mourir
on peut leur briser les papes pour
tester des prothèses pour les pour les
jambes
harlan le concurrent direct de la
société marshall funds est déjà implanté
dans l'allier le groupe possède
également un élevage en angleterre c'est
là que ce film a été tournée
clandestinement par une militante de la
cause animale
plus d'un millier de beagle son temps
passé ici un employé pour 300 chiens des
cages rarement nettoyées des gamelles de
nourriture l'idée une fois par mois
les beagles sont des chiens réputés pour
leur docilité mais dans de telles
conditions il est difficile de ne pas
être agressif personnes pour les séparer
quand ils se battent les bêtes blessées
sont invendables
on les laissera mourir seule possibilité
pour les autres de venir des mers
reproductrices hyper rentable ou servir
de cobaye pour la science dès l'âge de
six semaines les beagles sparte pour
leur ultime voyage les laboratoires
scientifiques dans le morbihan un camp
de vacances fermés en milieu de semaine
pour graves irrégularités auraient été
gérée par une secte en effet le nom de
la communauté du sacre du sacré coeur de
saint parres les vaudes été citée par le
rapport de la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire sur les sectes
j'en viens maintenant à cette annonce
médical qui pourrait à terme donner un
espoir à tous ces malades atteintes de
la maladie d'alzheimer
il faut rester prudent mais une équipe
américaine aurait mis au point un vaccin
expérimental dont les résultats sur
l'animal sont encourageants pour
l'instant donc il ne s'agit que de
recherche
les explications vena thévenet lors de
la maladie d'alzheimer
les dépôts appelé plaques amyloïdes se
développe dans le cerveau on soupçonne
ces plaques de jouer un rôle dans la
dégénérescence des neurones pour lutter
contre ces dépôts les chercheurs ont mis
au point un vaccin expérimental chez la
souris
les scientifiques ont d'abord introduits
chez des souris
le gène humain responsable de
l'alzheimer afin qu'elles développent la
maladie
le vaccin expérimental a ensuite été
injectés dans le cerveau de ces souris
chez les rongeurs malades les plaques
amyloïdes ont alors régressé essayons de
stimuler le système immunitaire pour
qu'il détruise les plaques amyloïdes qui
sont caractéristiques de la maladie
d'alzheimer est notre espoir c'est
qu'une fois débarrassé de ses plates les
neurones puisse à nouveau fonctionner
normalement
mais la prudence doit rester de mise
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord les
expériences sur la souris ne permettent
pas de vérifier si la suppression des
plaques d'amyloïde améliore les
capacités mentales
ensuite les spécialistes ne sont pas
tous d'accord sur le rôle que jouent ces
plaques dans la maladie enfin rien ne
permet d'affirmer que l'expérience soit
transposable à l'homme sans qu'il n'y
ait de danger pour sa santé
et puis toujours aux états unis à las
vegas des pluies torrentielles ont
provoqué de très sérieuses inondations
dans la capitale du jeu installé en
plein désert du nevada les rues ont été
submergés par ces orages d'été des
automobilistes ont été secourus par
hélicoptères il n'y a pas de victime à
déplorer
de nouvelles pluies sont attendues dans
les heures qui viennent à rouen la
grandiose parade de l'armada du siècle
venant d'une trentaine de pays de vieux
gréements de magnifiques voiliers de
légende ont élu domicile dans le port de
la ville pour ce rassemblement qui
devrait attirer plusieurs millions de
visiteurs thierry curtet lewis-roberts
sur scène il y a le look book
le norvégien avec ses trois mâts et ses
2000 mètres carrés de voile le fleuve
porte aussi les acrobates du christiane
raby ch
un autre norvégien dans le coeur du
public ils font jeu égal avec les
gigantesques que trois mâts
sud-américain le guacamole vertendre
mexicain où le simon bolivar vénézuélien
sont pris d'assaut par les visiteurs le
plaisir des yeux et fugitif la mémoire
elle se nourrit de peu de choses toutes
simples parfois c'est même devenu une
tradition le mouche ne fera que cela
dure le jour de la fête on est un
souvenir puisqu'on après un détour on
allait boire un verre et puis la réalité
pour revenir et suivra les bateaux c'est
la première
tamponé votre degré d'autres ont plus de
chance invités privilégiés ils font des
envieux
c'est des bateaux de mereiles je les
dessine des lignes
arias et l'âge peut les toucher
l'armada tient lieu de passion partagée
la plupart des bateaux sont accessibles
tous les jours gratuitement vers 6h ce
matin l'un des navires les plus attendus
peut être le plus beau le libertad
argentin profitait de la marée pour
s'engager dans la semaine une longue
remontée de 120 km en persan labrune de
la mer 103 mètres de l'étrave à la poupe
180 cadets grimper dans les verres
ici ils sont à la parade en mer ils
réduisent la voilure partout n'étant
arrivé au port
ce n'est pas toujours le début des
vacances
nous sommes au corps il faut encore plus
signer nettoyer le bateau assurer les
visites car un bateau école comme celui
ci est un bateau très prenant alors en
nous voyant on a l'impression qu'ici la
vie est belle douce mais elle est très
dure très prenante
il faut que tout le monde travaille tout
le temps avant d'être au port au port et
après il ne manque plus qu un ou deux
navires ce soir enfin la fête va pouvoir
commencer
ou presque tout le monde sur les routes
de france les départs en vacances de
cette fan semaine deux journées classées
rouge aujourd'hui demain par milan qui
termine de france
et puis à bordeaux en fin d'après midi
25 km de ralentissements une circulation
dense dans la vallée du rhône
affluence dans les gares parisiennes 670
milles juillettistes
rien que pour ces deux jours le tour de
france avec finalement pour cette
sixième étape la victoire de l'italien
mario cipollini puisque le champion
belge tom steels a été déclassé voilà
pour le chapitre sportif mais ces
dernières 24 heures dans la caravane du
tour on a beaucoup parlé de ce que
certains qualifient de deux pages
légales à savoir l'utilisation pour les
coureurs de corticoïdes sous certificat
médical fleurs en voit trop philippe
deslandes
il flottait ce matin au départ un air de
déjà vu un air que l'on respire l an
passé sur le tour 98 une rumeur cuisent
une information du journal le monde
indiquait que le danois bo hamburger
aurait été contrôlé positif aux
corticoïdes puis innocenté par lui c'est
sûrement ça
cette lettre il n'y a pas encore un
projectile c'est pas vrai ce samedi à
l'issue du prologue quatre coureurs ont
été choisis par le traditionnel contrôle
anti dopage l'espagnol beltrame ne
colombien castel blanco l'américain
armstrong et bo hamburger ce que les
coureurs ne savent pas c'est que le cio
a accepté une nouvelle analyse qui
permet de détecter les corticoïdes dans
les urines un progrès réalisés grâce au
travail des spécialistes du laboratoire
national de dépistage du dopage à
châtenay malabry
selon le monde le coureur positif serait
hamburger mais ce coureur aurait fait
valoir un certificat médical qu'il
autorise à utiliser de la cortisone le
communiqué de l'uci est claire tous les
contrôles sont négatifs on peut même
lire les coureurs auront droit à
certains produits pour raisons
thérapeutiques
s'ils essayent dit non ce cas n'est pas
un cas de dopage
l'organisateur que je suis ceci tient
ainsi arrange
je n'ai évidemment aucun rôle à jouer
dans cette affaire aucune expertise
aucune expérience médicale qui soit de
nature à contester cette décision
vos hamburgers est donc parti avec les
autres vers mulhouse l'étape a été
animée par quatre hommes l'espagnol ses
réseaux et trois français guesdon le
champion de france simon et maignan et
quatre échappés seront rejoints à six
kilomètres de l'arrivée
une arrivée disputée au sprint et
remporté dans un premier temps par tom
steels qui croient bien obtenir sa
troisième victoire d'étape mais dans les
coulisses les commissaires de course ont
vu une irrégularité la sanction tombe
non mais tu que l'annoncent en salle de
presse que ce style de déclasser au
caire et puis le classement il est après
il faut le matin la dernière place au
classement il est fait là ce qu'ils
aient des classes et pour ne pas avoir
roulé droit il a mis en danger ce
bourada ici en bleu
c'est donc une troisième victoire
consécutive pour tripoli ni un exploit
jamais réalisé dans le tour
cheap au mérite son surnom de serial
sprinteurs
je vous propose maintenant cette page
spéciale consacrée au festival d'avignon
dont le coup d'envoi se produira dans
moins d'une heure et demie avec la
création de henry 5 de shakespeare la
seule pièce de théâtre présentée cette
année dans la cour d'honneur du palais
des papes un événement dans le rôle
titre philippe torreton que nous
rejoindre en direct dans quelques
instants
mais d'abord michel montante et vous
êtes sur place devant le palais des
papes pour nous faire vivre les
premières minutes du festival
effectivement bienvenue bonsoir pour
vivre avec nous les toutes premières
minutes de ce 53e festival d'avignon
alors tout d'abord pour vous faire
toucher l'énormité colossal du festival
d'avignon
laissez moi vous dire le nombre de
spectacles que les festivaliers pourront
voir 650 pièces de théâtre durant
vingt-neuf jours c'est à dire qu'à
avignon en 29 jours il y aura plus de
représentations théâtrales que dans la
ville de paris durant toute une année
mais l'énormité de ce festival ne cache
pas l'essence même de ce festival qui
est abu d'abord et avant tout celui
d'une fête fait 2 par et pour le théâtre
alors nous allons tout d'abord voir
comment la ville d'avignon s'est préparé
à accueillir cette fête autour du
théâtre avec un reportage marie mbono et
jaunes qui ont été voir pour nous dans
les rues d'avignon
comment la ville du vaucluse s'est
préparé à accueillir ce formidable
festival
les saltimbanques de luxe pour le
lancement du 53e festival d'avignon
et pendant ce temps dans d'autres
coulisses douze acteurs se préparent et
répète encore pour ory 4 la pièce dure 9
heures juste une question vous êtes prêt
si on est prêt je sais pas j'ai entendu
ça va lui ne se pose plus la question
le voile a gonflé à bloc pour le
festival si vous n'allez pas au
spectacle le spectacle ira à vous en
faire des anges toute la semaine venez
nombreux
45 spectacles dans le in presque 500
dans le off vous n'y échapperez pas même
dans les petites rues et puis leurs
avants s plus à navigation devient
difficile agiléo ram vous avez
les parades et s'enchaîner voici la
première avec les malabars le décor est
installée la soca dans quelques instants
henry 5 va rentrer en scène dans la cour
d'honneur du palais des papes et en
direct donc d'avignon nous rejoignant
celui qui va ouvrir ce 53e festival
philippe torreton s'il a encore besoin
de vous présenter
j'aimerais que vous avez été césar du
meilleur acteur pour votre
interprétation du capitaine conan de
bertrand tavernier
vous allez quitter la comédie française
ce soir à nouveau défi porté ce soir
donc la couronne de soieries 5
alors peut-être cette question à moins
d'une heure et demie de vatan hun sen
quel est votre votre état d'esprit on
état d'esprit c'est surtout de la joie
tout de suite derrière il ya de la peur
évidemment mais surtout une joie immense
d'être là et puis un à l'ewi je dirais
un honneur aussi s'est il ya quand même
un passé immensément glorieux notamment
par souvenir de jean viard kaka lycée
jean vilar à ce lieu et si je trouve ça
magnifique 50 ans après d'être là et
puis deux et dans les mêmes pierres avec
le lierre qui bat dans le vent et tout
alors justement philippe je sais mon
petit doigt me l'a dit que vous étiez
juré de ne venir dans cet endroit
mythique que vous évoquez qu'une fois
que vous auriez un grand rôle à tenir et
un grand défi alors justement comment
vous avez décidé de franchir le pas et
d'accepter ce rôle énorme dans les cinq
ici dans cet endroit aussi impressions
et intimidant qu une chose est d'avoir
des envies mais en même temps une autre
et que certains puissent les réaliser et
il se trouve que bernard faye graciées a
répondu présent c'est à cette envie que
j'avais eu cette envie égoïste de de
jouer ici sous la direction de jean
louis benoit et il a dit oui tout de
suite
donc c'est vraiment ce soir c'est un
grand merci à berne et un pour nous
permettre de vivre ce moment là alors
avant d'aller plus avant je vous propose
avec daniel wolfromm et renier
poissonnier de voir quelques images du
spectacle qui envahira cet endroit
mythique non moins de deux heures
pas de performances sans la lente
imprégnation d'un texte
siddiq torreton va devenir peu à peu son
personnage petit henry 5 en brochets sur
des piques
c'est pendant que leurs mères
cependant que leur mère folle de douleur
de leurs clameurs confuse des chirons
les nuages
un an de travail pour en arriver là
triomphant roi d'angleterre dans la cour
du palais des papes et dans shakespeare
le burlesque côtoie souvent les c'est
bien dans ce milieu que le roi anglais
vivait au début de la pièce avant de se
métamorphoser touché par une sorte de
grâce patriotique
quand j'aurai quitté cette vie dissolue
et payé ma dette sans me être engagée
plus je serai loin de ce qu'on dit de
moi et plus jeter jour l attente des
hommes la tante de l'adversaire
héréditaire surtout la cour de france
paul par depuis les eaux glacées à
l'image de son dauphin courant droit à
la catastrophe
le gibier élevé
suivez votre ardeur et tout en chargeant
crié dieu soutiennent harry l'angleterre
et ça change
le combat vers à l'écrasement de la
noblesse française par les archers du
roy henry ainsi donc shakespeare
immortalisera un cours la plus célèbre
bataille de la guerre de cent ans
et comme dans un conte plus tard tout
finira bien quand la princesse fille du
roi de france et poussera henry l
l'aimera goulûment
alors philippe torreton nous avons eu
hier soir l'extrême privilège d'assister
à une générale de cette pièce et on est
étonné quand on se dit william
shakespeare 2h45 durant la vie d'henri
5245 qu'on se dit oulala ouhlala et en
fin de compte on a été très surpris de
voir que dans cette pièce il ya tous les
ingrédients fait du théâtre populaire
c'est drôle ça parle de ces paillard ça
parle de sexe de rigolade de guerre en
fait c'est l'essence même du théâtre
populaire 9 ha oui je crois c'est le
sait la liberté absolue célia
shakespeare se refuse rien pour pour
parler à ses contemporains et pour nous
parler donc maintenant aussi à nous
c'est parfois c'est de la farce parfois
cdd long poème en vers en verrerie mais
parfois c'est de la prose parfois c on
est dans le dans l'épique on est dans le
tragique on est dans la comédie il ya la
dernière scène avec catherine ça aurait
pu être écrit par par feydeau c'est
c'est là où on a affaire un génie quand
même c'est fabuleux vous avez passé un
an en compagnie du personnage d'henry 5
est-ce que vous avez fini par percer la
complexité de ce roi qui est un débauché
dans sa jeunesse qui finit par être un
roi exemplaires un héros est ce qu'on
sait en vivant avec un personnage
historique comme henry 5 qui est qui il
est vraiment non c'est quand on ne sait
pas il sait pas le but et je crois que
shakespeare s'il était à ma place là je
pense qu'il dirait pareil je crois qu'on
est on ne peut qu' on ne peut que
s'intéresser à quelques aspects comme ça
d'un personnage et moi je me suis
intéressé à ce que shakespeare a écrit
sur ce personnage qu'il n'a jamais connu
donc voilà il ya plein de choses qui
nous échappent et c'est tant mieux par
contre on peut se raccrocher nous à
certaines choses qui nous qui nous parle
aujourd'hui ou qui nous qui me semble
intéressant de montrer moi j'aime bien
cette dichotomie entre le jeune prince
des voiliers est ce ce type qui du coup
devient roi et qui décide de manière
absolument volontariste de la de renier
son passé et de philippe dont moi même
deux heures vous serez face au public
dans la peau d'un riz 5 et dans cet
endroit mythique
est-ce que les fantômes qui ont habité
cet endroit je pense à jean vilar je
pense à gérard philipe
je pense à tous ces gens qui ont
fréquenté effet l'histoire du théâtre
est ce que tous ces gens là tous ces
fantômes présents ici ce soir
vous aide où est ce qu'ils font des
petits crochets flics on en sort sur
scène et qu'ils font peser une
responsabilité qui terrorise n'ont cessé
sans dépenser qui aide moi je sais que
jean louis bonnet vient de m'offrir les
notes de jean vila et c'est sont
vraiment des pensées qui est roi des
gens qui est qu'ils ont voilà qui ont
sacrifié leur vie même si le mot est
peut-être un peu fort parce que c'est du
un sacrifice joyeux quand même assez
tard à ce s au public à rendre des
pièces claire sainte évidente et nous
avec jean louis benoit c'est sûr que ça
a été notre credo pendant pendant deux
mois et demi et de répétitions c'est
comment faire pour que les gens
comprennent sorte en ayant vraiment
compris tout où le spectacle est rien
sacrifié sur l'autel d'une d'idées qu'on
aurait eu farfelues ou autre alors je
vais faire le messager de bonnes
nouvelles catherine trautmann était ce
matin en avignon pour saluer les acteurs
et aussi les festivaliers y ait
l'annoncé ce matin une très bonne
nouvelle pour les professionnels du
théâtre
nous l'écoutons c'était une conférence
de presse ce matin en avignon pour le
théâtre l édition pour le festival
d'avignon 110 millions de rands
d'augmentation du budget pour le
spectacle vivant qui me permet d'aider
les compagnies 624 compagnie en france
rencontre le public un peu partout dans
le pays
et puis c'est en même temps aussi le
théâtre de rue qui se retrouve pris dans
ce soutien qui lui est apporté comme
royal de luxe
et puis en même temps c'est ce soir
l'ouverture d'avignon avec le bonheur de
voir et de retrouver philippe torreton
et puis au programme de ce festival et
dans la cour d'honneur pour le deuxième
spectacle de la danse chorégraphié par
angelin après le blocage au titre
insolite personnes n'épouse les méduses
mais c'est seul wc blesse grenier ont
assisté aux dernières répétitions
le rouge est presqu'une presque car son
désir de perfection poussant jeu
prejlocaj a répété mille fois s'il le
faut les mêmes en vol
et ça vous ne l'avez jamais encore vu
des béquilles comme un prolongement des
corps des accessoires pour ces grands
oiseaux porteur d'inquiétudes
angelin prejlocaj n'hésite pas à manier
les ustensiles de notre vie quotidienne
pour les détourner pour les transformer
en tremplin et valoriser la grâce
l'effort est l'amour
la danse ne peut pas ne peut pas ne pas
être le reflet quand même de notre
époque
notre époque est violente elle est
sensuelle aussi ça va vite en fait donc
la danse doit doit se doit être un peu
témoin de tout ce à quoi la danse témoin
d'un monde cruel mais aussi du désir de
retrouver nos âmes d'enfant
alors il est temps je crois de vous
laisser repartir vers les loges
oui et je crois que je n'ai qu'une chose
à vous dire c'est un mot de cinq lettres
auxquelles vous n'allez pas me répondre
et juste à dire à nos téléspectateurs
que jusqu'au 31 juillet donc le festival
d'avignon et je voudrais juste vous
quittez avec un chiffre mais qui est
significatif en attend en avignon
pendant 31 jours on attend 150 mille
personnes c'est plus que pour la finale
de la coupe du monde de football il ya
presque un an jour pour jour
oui il va écouter c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle les principaux
titres en corse l'audition du témoin de
matignon il s'agit de clotilde valter
chargé des affaires de sécurité qui a
remis au juge des photocopies de ces
carnets nouvelle polémique autour du
rôle de l'état dans la sphère du sang
contaminé une note adressée à claude
evin 89 envisager l'hypothèse de ne pas
rappeler mais transfusés
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet puis le point route de valérie
maurice 20h50 urgence 00h15 le dernier
journal florence cupra je me retrouve
quant à moi demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie notre attention excellence en
soirée sur france 2
j'imagine